j'imagine que certains d'entre vous ont
divorcé enfin ouais ça qu'elle met tout
le monde à d'un cousin
ça s'est bien passé quand même non
d'accord ok bah ça chez justement
francesca que les divorces où l'on se
déchire où on se quitte fâché que c'est
fini c'est plus 2018 c'est pas 2019 non
désormais la tendance
ce sont les divorces à l'amiable et
c'est l'info vivrait dit plus est ce que
le divorce dans la joie et la bonne
humeur c'est possible si la tendance de
plus en plus de gens divorcent alagna
aujourd'hui amiable veut pas dire qu'on
est amis quand on divorce et qu'on
arrive main dans la main en se tapant
dans le dos chez l'avocat
c'est con on estime que c'est mieux de
palais devant le juge parce que d'abord
ça coûte moins cher ça dure moins
longtemps et s'il ya des enfants on
n'aimait pas dans le cadre d'une
procédure d'un conflit donc c'est quand
même la tendance heureusement ayant nous
en tout cas on pousse à ça est ce qu'il
vous arrive de les faire renoncer on
essaye un petit peu d'être sûr vraiment
que qui sont décidés mais certains le
font un peu contraint parce qu'un des
deux leurs deuxièmes plus je divorce bas
l'autre va suivre mais au fond de lui
forcément on n'est pas heureux donc on
essaie de voir si vraiment les deux sont
sûrs de ne et parfois ça arrive je n'ai
pas tous les jours david mais c'est marc
une dizaine de fois en vingt ans quand
même que des gens ont finalement sur cet
ensemble alors 130000 divorces prononcés
chaque année en france je israël un
mariage sur deux en gros qu'une en
divorce
le constat est pas terrible malgré tout
cette idée de divorce à l'amiable est ce
que ça vaut pour moi c'est un non sens
total comme une force amiable c'est pas
possible
si tu t'entends bien tu divorces pas
franchement il veut divorcer enfin on
peut se dire on ne s'aime plus l'amour
redhac trois ans on se respecte on est
brisé
ça voudrait dire que il y aurait cette
chance inouïe que les deuxièmes plus
généralement il y en a plutôt un qui
aime plus et l'autre qui est toujours
amoureux il y en a toujours un qui
l'aimé coin tranquille pour essayer ça
dans mon monde
ça n'existe pas dans le monde on casse
des assiettes
les gens ont cassé voiture avait fait ça
vous va chez eux
ouais j'ai ben oui il ya eu quelques
temps il ya eu un peu de casse
vous avez passé j'ai cassé des choses
bon quoi binger les ses habits je les ai
jetés par la fenêtre j'ai rayé sa
voiture oui ah oui dans la mienne ça
n'existe pas chez vous non les modèles
j'espère que le cheminot il écoute pense
il est parti là d'élevage christophe moi
j'ai vu dans un minou civilisé hoyé
bienveillant voit là où je pars du
principe que dans une séparation c'est
toujours 50 50 pour les torts y'en a pas
un caprice à la voix de la raison mais
parfois la mission a pris là-bas mais
voilà il faut être plus fort il faut
être plus fort voilà et puis à essayer
d'amener au toit alors prêt c'est pas
facile d'amener l'autre à la raison
parce que par exemple quand vous êtes
avec un animal pareil évidemment tout
est simple voilà mais est ce que par
exemple ça veut dire que vous envisagez
de ne pas j'allais dire effacé de votre
vie la mère de vos enfants ou votre ex
compagne je veux que vous pouvez faire
des noëls en sang mais je mets nom de
famille non seulement je ne l'envisagent
pas mais oui effectivement je le fais en
revanche ce qui est plus compliqué c'est
d'avoir son ex et sa chérie en même
temps mais c'est sûr elle vous laisse ça
ça c'est sûr obligé de dire c'est un
truc de bobos pour moi de bobos
parisiens genre on s'entend fait noël
chez l'un chez long et toi c'est un truc
de sauvage avec passion c'est culturel
non c'est mon simple quand on se déteste
on se déteste on fait pas noël est
attendu chez l'un chez l'autre dans un
monde civilisé en france et peut-être de
prendre un peu sur soi et de soutien
après tout pour le bien commun tour
n'avait pour les autres choses on essaie
d'avancer ensemble ça finirait par un
meurtre mahdaoui de renouvellement est
telle qu'elle meurt trop d'accord ok
caroline
ben non pas du tout david francesca moi
je suis pour dédramatiser toute sorte de
rapport et dont le divorce et je suis de
l'avis de cet avocat je pense qu'il faut
aller vers quelque chose de plutôt doux
plutôt sympa pour tout le monde on
s'aimait embrassons marin dimanche à
lattaquié
non mais je parle pas de moi mais je
suis pas concerné mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que j'ai vu en tout cas c'est
ce concile vatican ii et là se trouve
dans les exigences de ses terres alors
en corse mais ça existe
voilà la tendance du divorce à l'amiable
est ce que vous comprenez où est ce que
vous ne comprenez pas eh bien vous ne
comprenez pas à 10% mais vous comprenez
à quatre mains
maintenant sur le plateau comme sur le
plateau